let's pop it rockstars my name is mt and
marvel studios just dropped two tv spots
for shang chi and the legend of the ten
rings due out this september because i'm
not sure if you remember but those
terrorist jerk holes will kidnap tony
stark and forced him to do arts and
crafts with the shrapnel hearts and
scraps yeah they're still out there but
thank goodness shanxi is here to run
counter-terrorism like the asian jack
bower that he is these new power and
call tv spots have got a couple new
shots that we of the speculation nation
have yet to see before so let's take a
look at these to see if we can't spoil
the movie for ourselves shall we my nerd
babies now the most surprising piece of
new footage in the power tv spot has got
to be the inclusion of these freaking
firebirds majestically flying around
like it was shangqi and the order of the
phoenix in this [ __ ]
but i don't actually think these birds
are phoenixes at all i mean if i were to
take a stab at it i would guess that
these are actually another type of
mystical firebird called the fenhuang
hopefully i'm not pronouncing that wrong
according to chinese legend the fenhuang
is the king of all birds and was born in
fire with the beak of a rooster the face
of a swallow the forehead of a fowl the
neck of a snake the breast of a goose
the back of a tortoise the ass of a stag
the tail of a fish the fire of a fire
the system of a down and a partridge in
a pear tree good god that's a lot of
[ __ ] now these hot ass birds are just
our latest look into the fantastic
beasts of shanghai but where to find
them i'm willing to bet that the fan
huang and this shot are flying through
whatever magical land lies on the other
side of this lake possibly on the other
side of the scaly red door on the side
of this mountain this door could be a
doorway to this mystical land populated
by beasts of chinese legend kind of like
a pocket dimension and what's also
interesting to note here is that in
chinese culture the fenhuang is
regularly depicted alongside a dragon as
a symbol of balance and are often
associated with the yin yang so that
makes me wonder if there isn't secretly
a huge giant mama fenwong that was meant
to be the opposite of the great
protector dragon of the sea with both of
these interdimensional creatures being
connected to the very power sources
channeled by the tan rings because i
believe that the ten rings fall under
the category of an mcu relic a concept
introduced by mordo in doctor strange 1.
play the clip john this is a relic some
magic is too powerful to sustain so we
imbue objects with it this
is the staff
of the living tribunal
[Music]
i'm thinking that this is why the
mandarin's rings are blue to represent
the water dragon slash the great
protector the source of his power while
shang cheese is more of a fiery yellow
representing the fiery power of the
chinese phoenix of the air these
trailers definitely appear to be telling
a tale between the forces of air and the
forces of water and this seems like it
will be further symbolized with this
fight between wenwu and zheng nan in the
movie but before i get into that i want
to thank mecharina for sponsoring this
video contrary to a lot of internet
rumors i am not a deadly robot built for
mechanized combat i know that's going
around please stop spreading that though
i do occasionally like to play one on a
mobile game because that's the safest
way to do that macarena is a tactical
5v5 shooter that's fun looks great and
runs smoothly on any device i've been
working on my battle skills in quick
matches i'm starting this battle off in
my panther mech because he's fast and
has a short reload time and also
panthers i love panthers black panther
let's go i'm gonna charge into this
battle behind some of my teammates
i got an assist on that kill i'm a great
teammate okay my defensive maneuvers
could use some work and my panther back
is dead but that's okay i get to respawn
four more times in this battle in my
other mech so
i'm covered i'm gonna build up that
panther so that he can survive longer
mecha arena has just launched globally
and they're running a huge celebration
event in game right now with loads of
awesome events and some amazing free
welcome gifts if you start playing
between august 9th and august 19th which
you definitely don't want to miss out on
it's completely free to play on android
and ion west right now and you can use
my link in the description or scan my qr
code to get one mil spec skin 500 acorns
and 70 000 credits to help kick start
your game and if you're quick you can
add me to friends as new rock stars and
we can play some matches together so
don't wait around seriously i'm in this
panther mech all alone but moving on the
power tv spot ends with shanxi trying to
teach his name's pronunciation to katie
on a plane because as established in
earlier trailers shanxi changed his name
after he ran away from magic isis so
katie had no idea who his name really
was my guess is that this is when katie
and shanghi are first headed to majapur
to watch wong get his ass beat by
abomination you know after bragging to
everyone and commentary about that one
time he went one on one with black dwarf
and beat his ass now he's probably in a
in a big load of trouble and he's like
oh [ __ ] and what have i gotten myself
into i can't beat this man
now onto the call tv spot where we get a
few new interesting shots including this
shot of wenmu moving all 10 rings to his
right arm presumably to give that arm
more power to show that rude ass ground
who's boss because how dare the ground
just be aground hashtag the ground
followed by this shot of wenmu's army
saluting their fearless leader by
raising their weapons in the air like
they just don't care weapons that appear
to be based on the science of the ten
rings themselves as they seem to be
running off of that same blue energy
power that courses through the
mandarin's rings whenever the mandarin
uses it and you can also see razor fist
among them like the affirmative action
higher that he is and he of course can
also be seen later on in the trailer
slicing this bus in half with his highly
impractical knife arm that also appears
to be channeling some type of energy
like those ten ring soldiers but
naturally the cooliest shot of this tv
spot is of course at the end when shanxi
looks like he's about to give his dad
the whole tan ring kamehameha wave it is
so dope how the rings spin to seemingly
channel and contain these extra
dimensional energies for one massive
blast it sort of reminds me of that
asgardian shield generator that curse
destroys in thor the dark world it's
going to be really interesting to
discover the magical science of the ten
rings and how it relates to other relics
like the staff of the living tribunal or
all the sling rings of camera touch and
if shang chi's golden ring energy
somehow relates to the golden magical
energies that mcu sorcerers love to use
for their magic all the time because
they look very visually similar and have
a good feeling that wong's main function
in this film is to remind general
audiences about the concept that magic
in the mcu is just beings or relics
channeling energies from different
dimensions you're not ready for that but
what do you guys think about these new
showing cheat tv spots are you excited
for shang chi let us know in the comment
section below my nerd babies thank you
guys so much for watching this video
please follow me at mastertainment on
twitter and instagram if you want to see
me post some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly please follow us on new
rockstars wherever we are and when you
do make sure to hit that notification
bell so you can get notifications
whenever we upload a video and make sure
to look at all of our dope shirts and
other merchandise at
newrockstarsmerge.com but yes thanks
again for watching this video and i will
see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you